all right let's get to the email mailbag
for the week if you have something to
say and you feel like it's worth me
checking it out you can email info
davidpackman.com sometimes we will grab
a YouTube comment here or there or a
Twitter reply or a Facebook post or
whatever the case may be but not this
week this week it is all bona fide
emails the first coming from Chris in
fact I received a number of beautiful
messages and some trolling about my
covid illness which spread through the
house like a virus which it is uh last
week Chris said sorry to hear about your
coveted illness I hope you get better
soon and have no long covet effects I
got it back in August for the first time
and luckily my sickness wasn't too bad
other than a headache for a day
thanks for everything you do and I wish
you the best for you and your family yes
I had it worse than a headache for a day
um in fact there was about a 28 hour
period where I was as sick as I can
remember being and I got all sorts of
different messages there was someone who
wrote to me and said that they put
hydrogen peroxide in their throat now
why am I saying it that way because
that's the way they wrote it you can see
that message on my Twitter and Instagram
they said they put it in their throat
and then something about lemon juice I
didn't do that I didn't introduce light
and heat inside the body I didn't use
bleach or any of that stuff
um and fortunately fortunately
it wasn't as bad as it could have been
it was pretty bad but it wasn't as bad
as it could have been and I appreciate
all of the messages from everybody
Sharon wrote in about what is a very
contentious topic and about which I have
made a decision
and I'm going to ask you to respect that
decision you don't have to like it but I
am going to need you to respect it
Sharon wrote in about interruptions and
Sharon said hi I enjoy watching your
show often Christo ivalis has a YouTube
show and when he shows a political clip
we see only the clip on the screen you
don't see my mug and he does not share
the screen or interrupt
have you ever gotten to see a movie with
someone and they talk or try to get your
attention during the movie they ruin the
movie I lose the joy of the moment when
there are constant interruptions it's
nerve-wracking and I generally end it
before the show is over I so wish you
would not interrupt your Clips or other
featured program thanks Sharon so listen
I get it there's two views on this one
is David shut up just play the clip and
don't say anything start to finish the
other view is I can get the clip
elsewhere the reason I'm watching you
David is for your commentary and so
manage it the way you want to manage it
I have made the decision because no
matter what I do people complain if we
just play Clips Long clips and I don't
say anything a lot of people say it's
not even it's like not even really your
show anymore you're just playing a clip
I've made the decision much like during
live streams where we watch a debate or
a rally I will open
I'm trying to offer something in
addition to just being a repeater of
clips and so I completely respect people
who don't want to see me or hear from me
during Clips there are lots of clipping
services and Twitter users who will just
post clips and no commentary I've made
the decision for the show for what the
show is that I will use my discretion
and sometimes you'll see my face during
a clip and sometimes you will hear me
say things and I will try to strike the
right balance as always with peace and
love you know I I will try to strike the
right balance and do everything that
everybody wants me to do the best
possible way but there are going to be
interruptions because that's the format
of the show and maybe Crystal ivalis has
decided on a different format and that's
a beautiful thing we can all have our
formats and we love you Sharon that's
the important thing we received the
commentary with absolute peace and love
Jason wrote in and said I think the left
is in trouble
writing with the absolute disaster the
Republican party has become more and
more people in my Social Circle are
voting Democrat do you believe that as
more people move over to the left that
the left as a whole is in danger of
becoming more Centrist thanks for uh
taking the time to read the question and
for producing amazing content no I don't
actually I just don't believe that's
happening because there's two things
that are taking place here there are
people who vote for Democrats
because
they love the Democratic platform
and there are people who vote for
Democrats because they find it to be the
better of the two options that have a
shot at winning but the truth is that
the Democratic electorate is actually
far more to the left of where the
elected officials are so
it's already a very Centrist represented
party
and because of a combination of
different factors including the way
districts are drawn and so many
different things
what I'm actually seeing is a Democratic
party that at least on paper has
continued to move to the left now
whether the elected officials move to
the left sort of remains to be seen
still but I don't think that that's the
case I also think that this is a sort of
temporary
aspect where disheartened Republicans
who don't like Maga either don't vote or
vote Democrat I think eventually the
Democratic party is going to figure it
out and they're going to get away from
Maga and go back to something else so I
don't believe that that's going to be an
issue I think democrats should take
victories while they can Sam wrote in
about foreign pronunciations and really
is not happy with me Sam said on the
November 29th show you pronounce the
word Uruguay
in what I assume to be a Spanish
pronunciation accompanied with the
phrase Uruguay please folks
isn't isn't my audience the best this
makes me wonder
when you were talking to your
Argentinian friends about American or
English people do you expect your
Argentinian friends to pause their
native accents and pronounce American
names terms phrases in an American
accent and British names terms and
phrases in a British accent that's kind
of weird but or is this just an
expectation you wield towards Native
English speakers for example if your
Argentinian friend was to say to you I
think Donald Trump is even worse than
Boris Johnson in Spanish would you
expect them to use American and and
British accents for the names right
Donald Trump
Boris Johnson
um no I would not expect them to do that
listen it folks
I'm doing hours and hours of content and
I will interject flavor and part of the
flavor is Americans pronounce Uruguay in
what seem like absurd ways you're a gay
I found I mean it's come on so I'm just
it's just a reminder of the way that
it's pronounced Uruguay that's all it's
not to be offensive it's not to
criticize anyone it's not because I
expect Argentinian people to do
something when they say a British name
it's just a podcast and a YouTube
channel Sam all right let's all take it
easy it's just a little joke it's sort
of like when I will say my birth city of
Buenos Aires
I could pronounce it in these mangled
American ways Buenos Aires that is Iris
it sounds almost like a disease
and it is very much not a disease my
friends Buenos Aires
um we're just having a good time all
right let's not take ourselves too too
seriously Peter wrote In
and Peter asks an important question and
says subscribe is free yes David to
subscribe is free is that correct a
membership costs but to subscribe costs
nothing if that is so then tell people
that this is reads like a haiku
it costs you nothing to click on
subscribe it only indicates you affirm
the show if it costs nothing and you say
that over and over and over you'll reach
3 million in no time subscribe also
tells YouTube something positive is that
also true let people know that as well
if I've got it right let me know Peter
you have it a hundred percent correct
when you hit that subscribe button on
YouTube it is free
you are affirming the show
and it does tell YouTube something
positive which is recommend this chaps
videos to more people
so I say to you today
hit that subscribe button my friends
it's a very very important thing Stephen
wrote in and says hey David long time
listener here just something I thought
about the other day isn't Trump
announcing another run kind of like him
admitting but not admitting that he lost
in 2020 the whole system is rigged but
also vote for me if he truly believed
that it was rigged why would he try to
run again thanks for the time so this is
so great because they have answers to
all these questions and it's sort of
like a if you stupid answer stupid
stupid questions sort of thing you and I
might say
if you won in 2020
you can't run again because you can't
you can only you can only do it twice
you can't do it three times they say
well we were the rightful winners based
on the will of the people but they made
Biden president so we I still got to run
I get to do two terms they figure that
one out next one
if it's rigged why would people vote
if people voted in 2020 for you but they
gave it to Biden wouldn't it just happen
again why even bother to run and then
they say
we just need to win by enough
that they can't rig it ah they have an
answer you know whenever you think
you've got them in a logic pretzel they
always have an answer
Ryan wrote in about gift memberships one
of my favorite topics and says hey David
and team I'm wondering if it's possible
to gift memberships to specific people
I thought you mentioned it was a feature
when gift memberships were rolled out
but I could be mistaken yes here oh and
cheers and hope your daughter is feeling
healthier this week yeah she had the
easiest run of the covet it lasted like
24 hours it was crazy actually how
quickly uh she she was doing better
faster than everybody okay
how to gift a membership to a specific
person
you go to joinpakman.com
you sign up you check that this is a
gift button when you complete the
process there's a pop-up and it'll say
who do you want to send the gift to you
type in their name you type in their
email Bing Bang Boom it is that simple
my friends very very easy Josh wrote in
about the white paper David sir great
job on the building arguments without
Burning Bridges white paper despite
being an inherently racist document
that's a joke the paper provides
valuable insights and suggestions for
engaging in good faith conversations
about difficult topics I look forward to
referencing this document to improve my
arguments and methods folks the white
paper is available to you for free you
go to davidpackman.com guide
davidpackman.com guide it is free you
type in your email address we send you
the white paper eight or ten page
document I should figure out how many
pages it is
which contains a treasure Trove this is
an original document that we put
together on how to have conversations
with people with wacky political views
get them to reconsider their beliefs
without ruining the relationships check
it out
we have a great bonus show for you today
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at joinpakman.com
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not Dave Pacman yeah thank you and you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
get yourself a discount we'll see you
then or otherwise back here on Monday